this video is sponsored by Skillshare
Charlie Kaufman is an American
screenwriter and film director renowned
for his uniquely structured reflexive
and theoretical writing style a style
that pushes against the borders of
conventional storytelling and pursues
new entry points into the creative space
of communication Kaufman has written
films such as adaptation Being John
Malkovich Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind
Synecdoche New York animal ISA as well
as several other works
Kaufman's films contain incredible
cinematic technique surrealistic senses
of time confusingly poignant character
developments in many other distinctive
qualities however this will not be so
much about Kaufman's films but rather
Kaufman's apparent philosophy
most of Kaufman's work deals with the
concept of self identity more
specifically our awareness and concern
with who we are and how we are
experienced in the minds of others this
idea can perhaps be neatly expressed
with a quote by 17th century sociologist
Charles Cooley who said I am not who you
think I am
I am not who I think I am I am who I
think you think I am which is to say we
are who we believe others see us as in a
constantly evolving feedback loop
created out of our actions other
people's perceptions of our actions and
our assumptions of their perceptions
throughout his writing Kaufman explores
how we work through this convoluted
house of mirrors attempting to find and
live with our true self
[Music]
just walk like yourself watch what's
this
I gotta go what
we all have sides of ourselves that we
hide we have things that we do in like
that we are ashamed of things we don't
understand or can't seem to control no
one exists without vices without flaws
some flaws and traits so unpleasant and
off from the shared game of normality
that we can sometimes become
insufferable to those who get close
enough to us as a result most of us
exist socially more on the surface of
our self omitting the more complex and
difficult elements of who we are in
order to fit in or experience smoother
social interactions
it is perhaps reasonable to some degree
to play along with this social game and
to withhold some heavier darker
information and qualities of ourselves
so to avoid burdening others with our
dysfunction very well knowing that
everyone is also dealing with their own
however there also needs to be a place
and opportunity to access share and
connect over these dysfunctions for the
same reason be it that everyone is
dealing with them but rarely is anyone
sharing or talking about them we spend
so much of our life trying to contrive
and exist as the best versions of
ourselves in the minds of other people
and thus we can easily become lost or in
a strange state of confusion over who we
really are or who people really are
arguably it is art philosophy and any
other creative act that allows us to
somewhat turn our perspective onto our
true self and dig deeper into the core
of who we really are
as individuals and as a collective art
and philosophy let us say what we cannot
normally they let us meet with others in
the deeper or darker recesses of our
minds talk about what's there and
connect on a level only possible in such
a place however in order to successfully
do any of this we must first be willing
to face and share our self with complete
vulnerability and authenticity or at
least try when writing and discussing
writing Kaufman defends with great
conviction the importance and value of
pursuing and expressing art creativity
and perhaps life in general with honesty
and self truth no matter how convoluted
dumb strange boring or scary we might
feel in the process say who you are
really say it in your life and in your
work
tell someone out there who is lost
someone not yet born someone who won't
be born for 500 years your writing will
be a record of your time it can't help
but be but more importantly if you're
honest about who you are you'll help
that person be less lonely in their
world because that person will recognize
him or herself in you through the
creative process and perhaps in many
other aspects of our daily life it can
be found that in order to do anything
novel or earnest we must risk having our
deepest and most vulnerable qualities be
rejected we must risk sounding dumb
acting weird being wrong or feeling bad
we must risk all of this in order to
ever share anything real about ourselves
and avoid living and dying without the
world ever really seeing who we are in
Kaufman's film adaptation he writes a
film literally about him writing a film
more or less about him Charlie Kaufman
the character in the film struggles
constantly with the feelings that he is
wrong boring cliche self-indulgent and
disingenuous while writing the film he
is in it myself into my screenplay
that's kind of weird self-indulgent it's
narcissistic solipsistic it's pathetic
I'm pathetic I'm fat pathetic I'm sure
you had good reasons Charles you're an
artist to avoid any possibility of
spoiling the film all that needs to be
said here is that Kaufman obviously
still wrote the film in spite of these
things likewise by facing our
insecurities fears confusions and
whatever else by recognizing that we
probably are all of these things and
still muscling through the process of
sharing or expressing ourselves anyway
we might find some truth in our self
worth sharing and more likely than not
we might help others find some truth in
themselves as well
Kaufman often appears to address the
idea that we're all struggling with the
same fundamental thing whether we
realize it or not we are all condemned
by the same consciousness and the same
condition an awareness that we are
trapped in a mind in a body in a world
in a universe thing with no idea what
any of it really is or why it is
your brain right now doesn't know why
your brain right now can wonder why your
brain is right now as these words hit
the part of your brain that processes
words and ideas your brain thinks about
itself wondering what it is somehow
using you as a method of Inquisition
horribly failing and then putting the
burden onto you like how a plant is
confined to its fixed roots in the
ground destined to grow contribute some
purpose towards the ecosystem around it
of which you will never understand or
care to understand and then die off with
a changing of seasons so too do we live
in extra bleak confined to the roots of
our being different than the plant
though we of course live knowing that we
are in the same sort of way stuck in the
ground with no control over the nature
of our condition destined to live and
die with the seasons whether we are
aware of this awareness or not no matter
how rich famous smart or powerful anyone
might be on the surface we all share in
this in Kaufman's film animal ISA the
main character is a successful
motivational speaker almost worshipped
by those he encounters but yet as an
audience we see how broken confused and
flawed he really is for Kaufman rather
than hiding or being dishonest about the
struggle we all go through it is through
the sharing of our experience of this
struggle with authenticity and honesty
that helps us uncover it so we can face
it grapple with it and hopefully
transmuted into something beautiful or
helpful ultimately no matter our efforts
to know who we are and who we aren't is
an incredibly hard constant and abstract
effort it's fair to argue that our true
self is sort of like a target just close
enough to see but too far to ever really
hit always changing or moving away from
us as we live our life and encounter
more and more of the world however
regardless of how hard Kaufman and his
work offers us a reminder that in each
moment we should aim and shoot towards
this target as best we can in our work
our relationships and our everyday life
this video was sponsored by skill share
first and foremost before saying
anything further about skill share it is
important to mention that a great deal
of thought and consideration went into
whether or not it was
to associate this channel with any
brands or products after consideration
with the sustainability and quality of
resources of this channel in mind the
decision was made to allow sponsors so
long as sponsors don't affect the
content or topics covered on the channel
furthermore there will be a filter
through which brands and products go
through in order to ensure that whatever
is promoted is considerate of you the
viewer and might provide real value with
this in mind Skillshare is this video
sponsor you have likely heard of
Skillshare if you frequent youtube
however a skill shares presence on
YouTube doesn't diminish skill shares
offerings it only means they know where
their audience is and how to reach them
in today's world if you aren't familiar
skill share is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills whether you want
to learn about new subjects understand
the fundamentals of a skill or better
assist the development of your career
skills share has a uniquely curated
source of information that can possibly
help you on your journey in reference to
the topic of this video only you can
know what you want to say or express but
skills shares courses can perhaps help
you begin or better figure out how to
say it specifically in terms of writing
a course entitled demystifying poetry
how to use lyrical language for more
powerful creative writing is an
interesting course available on
Skillshare the course teacher hanifa
durab keeve provides insight into
alternative more lyrical writing styles
that are often neglected in traditional
writing courses he covers various
methods of forming tone imagery and
conceptualization that can be really
helpful and applied to any writing genre
not only might a course like this be
harder to find elsewhere but when put up
against other more traditional in-person
classes in workshops Skillshare is very
affordable with an annual subscription
of less than $10 a month it is also
worth knowing that a Premium Membership
gives you unlimited access so you can
join any in all of the classes and
communities that might be of interest
because Skillshare is sponsoring this
video there is a link in the description
to sign up for a two month free trial of
course thanks for watching in general
and see you next video
you
[Music]